el de la foto es mi abuelo me vuelo del
miro yo de niño me gustaba mucho
escucharlo cuando me platicaba que de
joven se fue en barco de san francisco
alaska o contarme de su sobrino buscar
que murió escalando la montaña más alta
de américa el aconcagua
yo solía tener grandes sueños de
aventura pero como era de esperarse tuve
que madurar y los olvide paso el tiempo
me dediqué a estudiar trabajar cuidar a
mi familia y alcanzar los objetivos que
yo consideraba que eran obligatorios
hasta llegar un momento en mi vida hace
un par de años en que por primera vez
realmente tenía tiempo para mí
en ese momento recordé mis mis sueños de
infancia los cuales aunados al hecho de
vivir en un lugar con gran cantidad de
ríos lagunas y costas me dieron la idea
de explorar mi entorno por agua tenía
que hacer una embarcación muy portátil
que pudiera llevar conmigo en taxis y
camiones así fue como en el 2016 me auto
regale de cumpleaños un kayak inflable
me eché mi kayak al hombro y me lancé a
explorar el estado de tabasco
poco a poco fui incluyendo estados
vecinos hasta abarcar parte de
centroamérica
visité lugares increíbles de una belleza
indescriptible que mejor prefiero hacia
las fotos a tratar de explicar tanta
belleza
y costas
amaneceres
cuevas islotes con sitios arqueológicos
en los islotes
rápidos
estrellas de mar
barcos naufragados
hermosos pantanos
islas de todos los colores de todos los
tamaños de todas las formas realmente
viví y experimenté lugares fantásticos
literalmente nadie en peceras gigantes
con plantas multicolores y gran cantidad
de pececillos vi belleza experimenté y
belleza por todos lados
pero tristemente también me tocó ver el
gran daño que podemos causar los humanos
a la naturaleza con la contaminación con
las redes abandonadas por los pescadores
las cuales matan vida silvestre 24 horas
al día y no solo peces también matan
tortugas aves en varias ocasiones nos
hemos encontrado patos moribundos
enredados en dichas redes
en este caso esos dos se salvaron no se
preocupen
mi primer gran aventura fue cuando mi
novia y yo atravesamos el país de belice
desde el poblado melchor de mencos en
guatemala hasta los cayos de belice en
el mar caribe cuando estábamos haciendo
la preparación de la aventura sacamos
una larga lista de cosas que nos
gustaría llevar cosas como una amplia
casa de campaña una cama inflable
garrafones de agua una pequeña estufa
sartenes cámara con tripié lámpara ropa
mi novia hasta una bocina bluetooth para
escuchar música quería llevar
en una expedición en kayak así como en
la vida hay cosas que son obligatorias
que tenemos que tener por ejemplo en
este caso un chaleco salvavidas pero
comúnmente hay muchas cosas extras que
se nos antoja tener que las queremos
llevar por si las necesitamos
consideramos que nos darán placer y la
verdad es que si bien es cierto que en
algún momento nos pueden proporcionar
cierta comodidad también es cierto que
constituyen un peso que tendremos que
cargar durante todo el viaje quitándonos
espacio agilidad y libertad así que para
determinar que realmente es importante
me pregunté si quería llevarlo y
cargarlo pero prefería prescindir de
ello el resultado es que termina
llevando únicamente como el 20 por
ciento o menos de todas las cosas que
tenían en esa larga lista tan es así que
en lugar de garrafones de agua llevé
este pequeño botecito en este pequeño
pequeño bote con filtro con el cual
tomábamos agua directamente del río
cuando no había poblados donde
abastecernos
en la mochila llevaba el kayak los remos
el equipo de campamento y gracias a que
viajamos muy ligeros nos podíamos mover
fácilmente en transporte público
inclusive cuando en el río nos tocó en
algunas ocasiones aguas demasiado
someras que literalmente teníamos que
caminar las las pudimos pasar
una una travesía en kayak es una
excelente metáfora de la vida te has
preguntado que has estado cargando de
más
comúnmente no nos damos cuenta pero la
realidad es que el carro lujoso la casa
en la playa
las joyas los miedos los prejuicios los
rencores son cargas que llevamos a
cuestas y es decisión de nosotros que
cargamos y que no el kayac me enseñó que
entre menos llevemos remamos más rápido
con menos esfuerzo y disfrutamos más el
viaje
el viaje fue una delicia una realmente
impresionante disfrutamos de la
exuberante selva beliceña la gran
cantidad de vida silvestre que había
todos los días había algo retador algo
interesante algo nuevo en el cuarto día
se nos unió mi buen amigo tomás que por
cierto los sueños compartidos con los
amigos se disfrutan más
cuando me encontraba animales peligrosos
como serpientes de agua o lagartos que
había muchos lagartos me daba mucho
miedo pero me encontré tantos lagartos
que poco a poco me fui dando cuenta que
ellos me tenían tanto miedo a mí como yo
a ellos
tanto sucedió esto que en el momento en
que nos encontramos un jaguar ese foto
reale no crean que la base de internet
la tomó mi cuate es tomás en el momento
en que nos encontramos un jaguar en la
ribera del río mi reacción fue decirle a
mi novia filma lo yo estaba tan
acostumbrado a que los lagartos me
tuvieran miedo y estaba tan emocionado
de por primera vez en mi vida ver un
jaguar en libertad cumpliendo mi sueño
de niño que en lugar de sentir temor
giré mi kayak y empecé a remar hacia él
en ese momento aprendí una gran lección
una triste realidad
no hay animal más salvaje y más
peligroso que nosotros los humanos y los
animales silvestres como los jaguares
los lagartos lo saben
mi segunda gran aventura fue expedición
gran arrecife maya en ella llevamos un
kayak inflable un poco más grande con el
cual remamos más de 500 kilómetros desde
majagual méxico hasta río dulce
guatemala explorando durante 17 días el
segundo arrecife más grande del mundo
aplicamos lo aprendido en las
expediciones anterior y todas las
travesías de viajar ligero por lo que
básicamente llevamos el mismo equipo
únicamente agregue unos garrafones de
agua dulce dado que ahora eran muchos
kilómetros por mar
nuevamente fue maravillosa la aventura
indescriptible diría yo navegamos en
todos los colores posibles de agua
vimos gran cantidad de vida silvestre en
su entorno natural lagartos de agua
tortugas de agua changos manatís rayas
delfines
infinidad de peces
una larga travesía en kayak te da el
tiempo suficiente para platicar contigo
mismo inclusive hasta para auto
contestarte alguna duda existencial que
pudieras tener una regla travesía en
kayak te hace más sencillo más humilde
más perceptivo y más empático con el
entorno y con la naturaleza yo diría que
es casi una experiencia mística
cuando cuando planeó mis expediciones
mis travesías utilizo google earth en
google el checo o distancias trazo las
rutas y las imágenes satelitales me dan
una muy buena idea de que voy a
encontrar en el viaje
en este caso para ambas expediciones un
cheque a detalle todas las fotografías
satelitales de google de la ruta
y verifique también la fecha en que
habían sido actualizadas eran fotos
bastante recientes no tenían ni un año
de que habían sido subidas y fue una
triste sorpresa una desilusión para mí
al estar en dos ocasiones navegando en
lugares que eran según google en total y
absolutamente vírgenes y despoblados
escucharlas el ruido de las sierras
talando árboles o gente haciendo
construcciones en ese momento comprendí
la rapidez de la destrucción no me lo
dijo ningún científico noche que ninguna
estadística sofisticada en internet yo
lo vi es realmente triste y alarmante la
velocidad con la que estamos destruyendo
los pocos muy pocos lugares vírgenes que
quedan en el planeta
los más de 3000 kilómetros que llevo
explorados en kayak me han dejado claras
básicamente dos cosas la primera hay que
vivir y viajar ligeros la segunda es
nuestra civilización no será destruida
por una guerra nuclear o por una
epidemia de un nuevo virus nuestro o
extraterrestres que nos colonicen el
principal riesgo que corremos es algo
más previsible más obvio más tonto diría
yo inclusive algo que pudimos haber
evitado principal riesgo que corremos es
destruirnos nosotros mismos irónicamente
por una catástrofe ecológica que todos
todos hemos estado preparando
por último lo que me gustaría compartir
te a modo de sugerencia o de consejo es
liberarte de cargas innecesarias que
impidan alcances tus sueños y respetemos
a la naturaleza para seguir teniendo un
lugar donde vivir y soñar gracias
[Aplausos]